when the phones aren't being answered
when the app isn't working when the
website isn't being updated and none of
these systems are integrated in real
time people feel lost people feel let
down people feel defeated pretty much of
an emotional roller coaster for
travelers here in Las Vegas and frankly
all across the country problems that
Southwest Airlines continue to snowball
hundreds of flights grounded it could
take days until Travelers get home we
have Team coverage tonight Victoria Saha
tells us how this may impact New Year's
Travelers but we start with Ryan Matthey
at the airport speaking with stranded
Travelers
yeah Vanessa and Denise it's been
thousands of canceled flights now
thousands of tired tourists tired of all
this you can see over my shoulder here
these are just a few hundred of the
thousands of bags from different
Southwest Airlines that have remained
unclaimed here 360 flights canceled
yesterday close to 250 canceled today
the vast majority of these cancellations
coming from the airport's biggest
Carrier Southwest
and I left Friday
Friday
what's today yeah hello traveling
troubles aren't letting us I don't know
when I'm gonna get home Karen Whitelaw
is one of thousands who can't get
through to Southwest National Flight
problems led her to try re-booking her
flight to New York until later next week
but she has to do it in person because
when she tried canceling her original
flight remotely I'm sure the site
crashed I tried through the app then I
tried online then I asked my daughter so
we're more tech savvy to help yeah and
they couldn't do it and I even offering
to see if they could switch it
themselves they're not even looking
Ernest Jones is trying to get his
nine-year-old son back to his mom in
Texas I really want to get home although
his flight isn't canceled the increased
rebookings and seemingly unreliable
Staffing means there's no room for
unaccompanied minors we got to try to
make it work some way somehow or get his
mom to fly here and buy another ticket
to a different Airline so that's two
tickets that's about another 800
probably at this time last minute most
of us are going to file a claim and even
if Flyers make it through their luggage
might not a Southwest representative
said three thousand unclaimed bags sit
on property do you even know if it's
here right now no I have no idea the
line that I was standing in is to just
get into baggage claim to speak to a
person clothes toiletries I have
prescriptions you know just think about
the things that we travel with every day
now the Southwest representative here
says that they are offering flight
vouchers refunds and accommodations
where they can but Travelers say that's
not enough especially considering the
days of work and vacation they've lost
all because of this the CEO for
Southwest they say two-thirds of their
normally scheduled flights from today
through tomorrow have been canceled
reporting live here at Harry Reid
International Ryan Matthey 8 News Now